brett
how certain are you of the fact that the
virus emerged from a laboratory setting
and not from the wet markets as we were
told originally
well even the chinese say it's not the
web market at this point
so nobody thinks it's the web market i
didn't know that i didn't know they'd
reversed
yeah oh yeah it's not it's not the wet
market that that much we know
um so you should you should watch the
brett's conversation with yuri
yep yeah and i will say there's been a
bunch of stuff that i'm eager to cover
since we talked a lot about coven and i
talked with
yuri another lab leak hypothesis emerged
this week which i found fascinating i
think it's crazy
but another version emerged a very good
paper
which argues that the missing period of
time that is to say the time when
the virus would have evolved to get good
at infecting humans which is
absent from our current time series and
conspicuously so
their claim is it's a hypothesis it's
well presented
the hypothesis is that that period of
time was accelerated and took place
depending upon how you read the paper
either in the lungs of
one of the six miners who got infected
in yunnan in 2012
uh or conceivably i guess it could have
gone from one minor to another but
it can't have been more than a couple of
them um but the idea is that this long
period of time of evolution or this long
sequence of evolutionary steps that we
would expect to see took place in the
lungs
of these miners which would have been an
odd place for a coronavirus to be which
would have accelerated the rate of
change
and that basically a tissue sample from
one of these miners made it to
wuhan which is why it emerges there at
the wuhan institute or on its doorstep
because that tissue escaped so the point
is
natural virus intermediate is a human
and it then gets transported to wuhan
where it accidentally escapes
i think this is nuts i i can't imagine
that this is the right explanation but
let's put it this way
your plausible alternative lab escape
hypothesis is now also circulating it
belongs on the map
of various possible hypotheses and what
i would say is the number of people who
are now
carefully ready to explore the idea of
lab leak
gain of function this landscape is
growing and it's about time so
um that's good the question was how
certain am i
not certain but i would say at this
point i would say
90 chance is conservative i think the
chances are very high it emerged from a
lab
and also very high that it was enhanced
in that lab
and then the last part of the question
was oh the yeah not the wet market
[Music]